Monday Night Football in Houston the
Texans take down the team that used to
call Houston home they were the Oilers
now that the Tennessee Titans 34:17 the
victory the Texans were down by 10 they
scored 27 in a row
final score 34 17 Texans had a franchise
record 281 rushing yards 97 of which
came on one play eight wins in a row for
Houston after starting own three the
first team in NFL history to do that and
they now have a comfortable two-game
lead over the Colts in the AFC South and
you know Peter for me the turning point
was that that moment where Mike Vrabel
and you know going for it on fourth down
has become the the cool thing to do now
in the NFL but sometimes it blows up in
your face the Titans were down 14 to 10
they go for it inside the five on fourth
and short it doesn't work next play 97
yard touchdown and it wasn't game over
but it sure felt like that swung the
momentum in a way that was very
difficult for the Titans to ever come
back from yeah I absolutely
unequivocally would have made the same
call not sure I would have run the same
play but I definitely would have made
the same call as variable did this was
not a game that was going to be won with
20 points or 21 or 23 points
this was going to be a game where he had
gonna have to score high 20s 30s to win
the game if you look at you know the
explosive weapons that that Houston had
that's my first thought I think my
second thought about this game overall
is that it justifiably all but ended the
the AFC South and all you have to do is
look at the future schedule of Tennessee
and understand that their toughest game
probably is with their biggest rival in
the division Indy but it's at Houston
and Tennessee and sorry I'm sorry
Houston enters this game right now
against the Indianapolis Colts having
beaten them early this year so even if
Indy wins it doesn't mean that Indy has
the tiebreaker if they tie atop the
division late in the year
I think Houston
has all but won the AFC South what do we
make of the Titans at this point you
know they are the ultimate
jekyll-and-hyde team this year they beat
the Cowboys on a Monday night they
trounced the Patriots by 24 then they
lose by 28 to the Colts and then they're
back on Monday night and they lose by 17
in Houston which Titans team is the real
Titans team you know to me the Titans
shining moment this year so far was when
they went to Dallas and won on Monday
night a couple of weeks ago and the
reason why that was such an impressive
victory for that team is that if you
look at what Dallas does well Dallas
runs the ball well and not a lot of
teams can defend the Dallas running game
and I think that night what my Treville
said was we are going to be tough and we
are going to beat this team with
physicality that's what they did in that
game Mike I think the one other thing
about Tennessee right now is and the
reason why I don't think it's over but I
think it's going to be really really
hard for them is that I really wonder
right now is there anything that they
absolutely can hang their hat on that
they do offensively and I know Mariota
had this great 22 out of 23 game last
night that's great okay but I just don't
see the consistency on offense and look
at look at this scoring graphic right
now I just don't see the consistency on
offense that you need to have to be a
very good team and a playoff team you
know I always say there's three types of
teams in the NFL teams that have
franchise quarterbacks teams that are
looking for franchise quarterbacks and
then the teams that have a quarterback
and they're not quite sure whether or
not he's gonna be a franchise
quarterback this is your four for Marcus
Mariota he's not a franchise quarterback
yet he's not a bust he's somewhere in
that that middle ground and at what
point do you say he just is who he is
and we're either happy with that or
we're gonna try to upgrade when all
these other teams are finding these
young quarterbacks who have been
spectacular early in their careers I
think
to be very hard this offseason to say we
want to devote the next six years of our
franchise to Marcus Mariota I think you
will end up doing that but and I like
them Mike I certainly think that it's
more likely than not that he'll be there
long term quarterback but there are some
things I see that worry me and I think
sometimes he holds on to the ball too
long he did it last night even though
his pocket was getting caved in a lot
you know by Houston you know I like a
Mike but I think you're right I think
that the Tennessee Titans
don't know yet if he's the long-term
franchise guy that you're gonna win
championships with and but again there's
a lot more to like than not to like
about him I just would hesitate this
offseason you know to making him
whatever the number is 26:28 million
dollar player you know we talked last
hour about how this explosion in
offensive production could get some
coaches fired who otherwise would have
been safe I think it does make some
teams less willing to give a guy for
five six years look at Miami Brian Tana
has had seven years to break one way or
the other and and when and and look it's
always driven by how many great
quarterbacks there are coming out in any
given draft but I think teams are gonna
be less patient not more patient with
quarterbacks going forward and whether
Mariota stays or not it may not be it
may be a Blake bortles type of a
contract where it's just a two or three
year deal so they can just continue to
kick the can and see if he becomes that
guy they need him to be Peter in my
opinion you look at Miami and and Ryan
Tannehill has just been hurt too much
and it would be hard for me to enter
this offseason thinking solidly that
he's our guy I think they need to either
bring in a Teddy Bridgewater type guy or
graph the guy in the first round and
have him compete with Dan Hill I just
don't think Miami has any choice
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports